hallo leute hier ist eure mal wanne bin
habe ich echt lang nicht mehr gemacht
mal wanne ist in der damals von ganz
vielen jahren als die kinder nach der
schule zu ihrem sportverein oder zu
ihrem job war kurs gegangen sind da bin
ich zu hause geblieben habe nach der
schule mein ranzen in die ecke
gepfeffert bin zum fernseher gerannt ja
damals hat man noch fernseher geschaut
und ab rtl 2 1 gemacht und mir ist mir
die ganzen nachmittags anime ist gegeben
ihr müsst dieses gefühl verstehen das
waren die superhelden
ich habe alle spiele karten gesammelt
alle titel songs konnte ich auswendig
und zwar immer mit dabei wenn es eine
neue ins neue abenteuer gab und heute
schaue ich youtube-videos deinen traum
also ich habe letztens digimon geschaut
und mir ist etwas aufgefallen dass meine
erinnerungen nicht ganz damit
einhergehen wie das so wirklich wahr
oder ich habe das gefühl dass ich mich
an dinge nicht erinnern konnte die
wirklich jetzt sehr auffällig sind und
als es mir dabei die bauern aufgefallen
ist habe ich mir mal andere animes
angeschaut so von früher und mir sind
noch andere sachen aufgefallen und
deswegen habe jetzt zehn animes
rausgesucht bei dem wir dinge
aufgefallen sind
die mir früher nicht aufgefallen sind
[Musik]
bleiben wir mal bei dir wohnen ich weiß
bestes intro super catchen jedem ii bis
heute du bist noch viel erleben
du musst diesen test bestehen
es kommt der tag okay aber wie oft
können sie die namen dort wiederholen
die erste folge besteht heraussägen nahm
100 mal zu hören
hey wer bist du denn ein name ist kein
roman und wo sind wir kommen in der
decke fällt ich bin kein roman und dann
kommt noch mal der computer der die sagt
koormann level keine ahnung attacke
seifenblasen forum und du denkst ja
alles klar
der disco wo man diesen namen habe ich
jetzt 100 mal gehört coro man habe ich
mir gemerkt ist täterin gespeichert und
dann legst dieser bastard editiert sich
und dieser name ist futsch get out of my
head dies das brauchst du nicht mehr
es heißt dass die who won ok und dann
geht das ganze spiel von vorne los wer
bist du denn auch warum bist du denn
jetzt so ich habe mich dediziert mein
name ist an humor ok argument das ist
schön und dann kommt natürlich noch mal
der computer das ist allgemein level
argument alles klar gemerkt argument
drittes argument zum glück bleiben sie
dann auch dabei dann haben wir da noch
zählen
mertes mondes darauf was ist das für
eine pose was habe ich sie geliebt es
war alles so starke planeten
kämpferinnen jeder art den namen von
jungen planeten und dann waren sie so
machen mich fertig mit der macht des
mondes und was fällt mir nach all diesen
jahren auf ich weiß dass ihr beweglich
sein müsst aber zieht euch doch bitte
mal was an da musst du nur ein windstoß
comment marilyn monroe lässt grüßen und
dann seid ihr unterwäsche nun köpfen ist
detektiv conan sehr geile anime und wenn
ich irgendwann mal jemanden umbringen
möchte werde ich mir da eine genaue
anleitung dazu geben dies schaffe ohne
dass mich jemand erwischt bzw
meine spulen nachverfolgen kann denn
ohne kommen wer jeder mörder
durchgekommen
nur er war so intelligent und hat sie
alle erwischt und ohne scheint du siehst
da genau wie du da das seil durch das
fenster herum ziehen muss und dann da
irgendwas befestigen muss und dass dann
den schlüssel durchs durch die tür sozis
dass es aussieht als ob sich die person
selbst umgebracht hat sehr große
empfehlung ein gleichzeitig sehr süßer
und sehr perverser animes trambahn halb
ich meine wir haben den großen panda
papa und eine doch recht schöne
liebesgeschichte und brüste nasse größte
masse große brüste nasse große brüste
die immer nicht immer aber sehr oft im
fokus sind die verwandlung von hama ist
ja hier mit dem warmen und kalten wasser
hat mädchen junge wenn ihr es nicht
kennen schaut euch das mal an und ja das
passiert nicht selten dass er nass
gemacht wird und dann eine frau ist und
dementsprechend immer noch ein dass das
oberteil hat und kein bh weil als man
trägt zwar kein bh details ist einfach
zu hoch
ich verbitte mir das peinlich und dann
gibt es immer noch irgendwo ein
perverser der sich da so drauf hat und
auf geld so ur golfs eine frau und sie
war sehr stark
sie hat sich werden können und giftet
bubis because they don't want to seek
bubis dem motto sea action und
lovestorys bubis ein anime an den ich
mich auch sehr schwach erinnern konnte
war wedding pietsch kennen vielleicht
nicht ganz so viele was wahrscheinlich
an dem längsten verwandlung spruch aber
liegt liebe ist eine blüte der show und
wie ist der name schon irgendwo verrät
verwandeln die sich wirklich in bräute
also immer also hochzeit freute und
danach kommt dann so eine zweite
verwandlung durch ein lippenstift in
denen sie dann zu so sailer monarchie
gewesen wären da so auch so kriegerin
der liebe und in den ganzen kampf geht
es um irgendwelche sprüche die mit liebe
zu tun haben dann geht so gänseblümchen
die gänse blues die gänse blume die gäbe
bliebe es besteht viel lieber spüre
meinen regenbogen der liebe
liebe
[Musik]
nintendo hat für diesen ohrwurm aber ein
plus von gibt es zu wenig sie sehen alle
aus wie disney prinzessinnen und ich mag
disney prinzessinnen und kinder es ist
sowieso toll also die erste prinzessin
pädagogisch wertvoll die großen
abenteuer von hamm taro sind nicht wie
anders zu erwarten abenteuer von einem
hamster und ein hamster erlebt halt
nicht viel wirklich was fand ich daran
früheren so spannend es sind abenteuer
von einem hamster pokemon allerdings
habe ich genau so in erinnerung wie es
auch heute sehe geile serie geile kämpfe
geile pokemon supergeil außer dass ich
damals wohl übersehen habe wie
entschlossen immer alles gewirkt hat wie
geht es dir
mir geht es gut
pikachu
yu-gi-oh ich weiß dass ich diese serie
sehr viel geschaut hab ich habe die
karten gesammelt und konnte sogar mit
diesen karten spielen aber ich habe
absolut keine erinnerung wie die story
war könnt ihr mal aufrecht in die
kommentare schreiben eine kurze
zusammenfassung
ich könnte natürlich auch zu wikipedia
gehen und das nachlesen aber
recherchieren ist was für anfänger
torrini ist wohl das höchste anime der
jemals gemacht wurde
auch wenn er mich ein bisschen an einen
lsd trip erinnert liegt aber nur so an
den ganzen farben und unser letzter
anime es hat mich dass mein taschengeld
gekostet jeden einzelnen cent habe ich
dafür ausgegeben den kurzen und
teuersten beyblade zu verkaufen toys 'r'
us wäre nicht heute das was es ist wenn
es nicht damals schon so viele blades
verkauft hätte ich also nur den für fünf
euro oder waren das fünf mal nicht das
waren schon euro auf jeden fall war das
mein letztes geld und dieser scheiß ist
nach einer woche kaputt gegangen und aus
diesem großen drachen kämpfen so ist und
was im endeffekt vorne badewanne
einstehen und super
wow cool voll die drachen und dann kam
die mutter rein und hat mich verprügelt
weil die badewanne zerkratzt hast das
war dass palin über allerdings manchmal
hat mich nicht geschlagen
meine mutter hat mich nie geschlagen und
jetzt gibt es eine von mir sehr wichtige
frage an alle schulkinder da draußen
gibt es so was heute noch so was wie
blade oder sammelkarten wo dann alle aus
irgendeiner serie sowas krass feiern das
ist so bei jeder hat uns auf dem
schulhof und jeder muss es haben
versucht so kugel oder ist das
ausgestorben das möchte ich gerne von
euch wissen schreibt mir gekommen und
ich werde es lesen an alle die nächste
zur schule gehen oder nicht mehr in dem
alter bis 15 sind möchte ich fragen habt
ihr diese animes auch so gefeiert seid
ihr auch nach der schule zum fernsehen
rand und dachte du ihr 40 oder war das
ein ausländerkinder ding weil ich kann
mich oft an meine ausländischen freunde
erinnern die hier hatten die gleichen
hobbys
ich wünsche euch einen schönen tag
macht's gut und ist dann was war das
unser lied beginnt immer mit du ri
wir sind frei